you're from scotland as well i am yeah
have you had kilt
experience i'm still traumatized by
something that happened to me um the
other day actually
so i went to my cousin's wedding and i
thought i'm gonna film the occasion
and then give it to her as a christmas
present and then
i was going through all the material and
somebody had obviously taken the camera
this wasn't me
um and it went all dark and i could see
like something moving around
and then i suddenly realized that it was
an up kilt shot of my cousin
it was horrible did you leave it in or
did you take it out
it's deleted oh you did you really yeah
i couldn't i don't want to look at that
dvd extras on the wedding
here's a shot here
because you were a model you did do
modeling for a couple of years
yeah so does this make you miss it or
did you just kind of think thank god i
don't do that anymore
[Music]
i do not like it at all i mean it was it
was an okay
way to earn money because i was working
in a pub before that so it was good for
that but
it's not something i ever aspired to do
in life and
there was a couple of things i had to do
like put a bucket on my head
in a casting which is rather strange but
as a model they
asked you to put a bucket over your head
yeah they were like shoes
oh it was about the shoes yeah they
didn't want any distractions
there's a buck over your head it's not
gonna be a distraction oh look at the
shoes of that lady with a bucket on her
head
wow what's that clanking sound
the last doctor who david tennant
everyone loved him
and everything i thought matt smith
young guy he's on hiding to nothing but
the two of you
but on the sunday morning were just like
everyone loved you it was brilliant were
you aware how risky it was
yeah of course i mean it's a massive
thing to take on um especially here
because it's such an
institution and and david tennant was so
popular and it was so successful in the
past but
but that's the exciting thing isn't it
because people actually
care about it and feel passionately
towards it so that's exciting
and i didn't realize you'd already been
in it with david i have yeah
yeah yeah and i played a suit there oh
there's a picture yes
definitely that's not a great look for
you
it's better than our baby
and so is that how they met you do they
is that well actually it's completely
unrelated because it's a whole new team
now sort of backstage and and everything
so so it's yeah it's completely
unrelated other than the fact that
the casting director knows me so you get
yeah and a call
tell you what it's just oh we'd like a
meeting or do you know that you're going
to be
the new assistant um well my agent
called me and said
they're looking for a girl to play the
new companion for the new doctor
so um so that's all i knew and i just
did an audition with the casting
director
and um and then i got a recall and i had
to um go into the bbc
sort of studios and i'd say i was
auditioning for something called panic
moon
which is an anagram of companion so they
take it that seriously they take of that
seriously yeah it is
top top top secret i can't use that
anagram anymore
start
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
no
but now the reaction to you has been
told me and you were
have you been voted to declare everyone
just said you're the sexiest doctor who
assistant of all time
yeah what's that all about well you were
a stripper in the first episode weren't
you piss your gram
not a stripper a kisser yeah not a
stripper no
is it kista grandma stripper yeah oh
it's an anagram of strippers
[Applause]
talking of emotional karen gillan uh
doctor who go boohoo because amy paul
and she go bye-bye
yeah uh she leave when are you what are
you out of it
um well i'm gonna go back next year and
then i'm gonna do um a few more episodes
um but it's not actually confirmed when
i'm actually gonna go and so i don't
know is it is it
a proper dead you can't no one really
dies
doctor who do they nobody does well it's
possible i don't know i have no idea
are doctor who fans do they sort of drop
ex-companions like a hot potato or are
you
a companion forever do you think i would
like to be a companion forever
oh no i think so because how cause
the whovians are kind of well known for
being quite
enthusiastic enthusiastic thanks
what sort of mad things have you got
said enthusiastic things
well there's this one guy who sends me a
postcard from every place that he goes
on holiday
and he just holidays consistently and
the last postcard that i received was
from my hometown
i was like oh my god it's like i hope to
i hope to bump into you
uh-uh he's nice no call the police i
like to hear from him
that's weird maybe he's in the audience
[Music]